hi there today we're looking at
supervised contrast of learning by
people from Google research and MIT now
this paper proposes a new loss for
supervised learning and you might
recognize that this is a big claim so
for ever now we basically use this
cross-entropy loss in order to do
supervised training of neural networks
this paper proposes to replace that with
the supervised contrastive loss and
let's jump straight into the results
here they say our supervised contrastive
loss outperforms the cross-entropy loss
with standard data augmentations such as
Auto augment and Rand augment so these
are some of the previous
state-of-the-art data augmentation
techniques used together with the cross
entropy loss and they say there are
supervised contrastive loss outperforms
them you can see here on image net which
is the biggest vision benchmark or the
most famous one this new loss the
supervised contrastive loss outperforms
these other methods by something like a
percent one percent is a big improvement
on image net right now so they claim it
is a big claim right you recognize if
this is true this could be a
game-changer basically for all of
supervised learning and supervised
learning is really the only thing right
now in deep learning that works so it
could revolutionize the field but so
here's the but it is actually not a new
loss to replace the cross entropy loss
and that's they do they do come about
this pretty quickly some and you don't
think they're they're dishonest or lying
or anything here but it is it is sort of
if you start reading you like what this
is a new loss it is not it is a new way
of pre training the network for a
classification task and so let's look
into this so if you look at what does
what does
mean to build a classifier in this is
what you usually do this is supervised
cross-entropy training you have an image
and the image here is of a dog you put
it through your network and you obtain a
representation so the representation
here R is this last layer or the
second-to-last layer and you put that
through a classification layer and then
a soft Max and what you get as an output
is basically a probability distribution
and let's say you have three classes
here there's dog there's cat and there's
horse and let's say the network doesn't
yet isn't yet trained very well so the
probability for dog here is fairly low
so this is basically what the network
thinks of that image like which class
does it belong to with what probability
I also have this label right here so the
labeled dog for that image what you do
with that is you do a one hot vector so
that would look like this so the one is
at the position where the correct class
is and then the cross-entropy loss takes
all of this and does the following
there's a sum over all your classes in
this case you have three classes and
let's call these the labels l and you
want to always take the label of the
class times the log probability that the
network thinks belongs to this class so
you can quickly see that this if the
label is 0 so for all the incorrect
classes that means this entire term
drops away and only if the label is 1 so
only the correct class that will result
in the log probability of the class
where the label is the correct label
right so in order to make this a loss
you actually have to put a negative sign
in front of here because you want to
this so this entire thing reduces to the
log probability of the correct class
this is what you want to max
semi's there for you if you want to
minimize something you need so you
minimize the negative log probability of
the correct class which means you
maximize the probability a a if you've
never looked at the cross entropy loss
like this it is important to notice that
you're gonna say hey all this does is
pull this here up right and it doesn't
do anything to the other ones but you
have to realize that this softmax
operation since this is a probability
distribution all of this is normalized
to sum up to one so implicitly you will
push these down through the
normalization right so what this does is
it pushes the correct class up and it
pushes the other classes down so this to
look at this is going to be important
later because if you look at what this
representation here does so again you
have the network produces a
representation here this is 2,000
dimensional and then it does it adds on
top this classification layer this
classification layer is simply a linear
layer and then a softmax on top so how
you have to imagine this is that there
is a representation space this 2010
shell space and the representations are
made in such a way that the labels such
that sorry let's have three classes here
the representations are made in such a
way that a linear classifier can
separate them correctly right so here
this would be like a boundary and then
this would be another boundary and this
maybe would be another decision boundary
so you can see that the linear
classifier can separate the classes well
that is the goal if you use this soft
Max cross-entropy loss that is
implicitly what will happen in the
representation space W all the cares
about is that the classes are on one
side of the decision boundary and
everything else is on the other side of
a decision boundary
so if if you have the network isn't
trained very well at the beginning and
you maybe have a sample of the green
class here it will push the network such
that the representation of that sample
will go on to the other side of this
decision boundary and it will push the
decision boundary at the same time to
make that happen more easily right so it
will optimize all of this at the same
time that's what you do that's how you
optimize representations so this work
here and another work has said wouldn't
it be great if the representation and
decision boundaries weren't just trained
at the same time for this but we learn
good representations first such that
classifying them becomes very simple and
in essence what this paper says is if we
have a representation space W shouldn't
images of the same class shouldn't we
just make them close together you know
so without caring about decision
boundaries we just want them to be close
to each other and we want them to be far
apart from other classes if that happens
you can see that a linear classifier is
going to have a very easy time
separating these classes later so that's
exactly what this paper does it has a
pre training stage and a training stage
so in the pre training stage this is
over here
su provides contrastive in the pre
training stage it simply tries to learn
these representations right like over
like down here such that without the
decision boundaries class think images
of the same class are close together and
images of different classes are far
apart which notice the the subtle
difference right to the cross-entropy
loss where you just care about them
being on one or the other side of a
decision boundary and in stage this so
this stage one and then in stage two
and there is where where it comes in
you basically freeze the network so you
freeze these weights down here these are
frozen you don't train them anymore all
you train is this one classification
layer so the represent actually freeze
also the representation layer here you
only train the classifier on top in
stage two but you train it using soft
Max and using the cross-entropy loss so
you you train the classifier in the old
cross entropy way using just normal
supervised learning the difference here
is that the stage one free training is
is what's training the network and the
cross entropy dose only trains the
classifier right so let's look at how
this pre training actually worked what
is using what it's using is a method
called contrastive pre-training now in
contrastive pre training and they have a
little diagram up here what this does is
if you look at the classic way of doing
contrastive pre train you have to go to
the unsupervised pre-training literature
people have kind of discovered that they
can improve a neural network by
pre-training it first in an unsupervised
way and this is also called some of
these methods are called self supervise
so the advantage here of self supervised
or unsupervised pre training is that you
don't need labels what you want to do is
simply to make the representation space
somewhat meaningful right so you simply
want the network to learn
representations of images that are
somehow meaningful right that are there
and here's how you do it so you want to
take an image like this dog here and
then you want to randomly augment this
image which just means you want to
produce different versions of the same
image in this case down here this is a
random crop it's cropped about here it's
still the same image but it's
a different version of it in the case
here you can see that it's flipped
left right and the brightness is
slightly increased so these are just
different versions of the same image and
what you also want are what's called
negatives negatives are simply different
images from your data set right for
example this or this or this you don't
care as long as they're different right
you just sample a bunch and what you
want so you're you're embedding space
and they make it big a deal here that
they are normalized and that seems to
work better but this is not necessary
for the idea to work the big idea is
here that if you have an image right
here let's say this is this is the dog
and the blue dots here are the augmented
versions of the same dog and the green
dots are all the other images in the
data set what you want is that the all
the images that come from the original
same image are pulled close together and
everything else is pushed apart right so
that's why these are called positives
and these are called negatives so the
contrast of training basically means
that you always want to have a set that
you pull together in representation
space and assets called the negatives
that you push apart so the network
basically learns about these random
transformations that you have here the
network kind of learns what it means to
come from the same image it learns to be
robust to these kind of transformations
it learns about the data in general and
how to kind of spread the data and
embedding space with these
transformations so this usually ends up
in a pretty good representation space
and people have been using this in
recent years in order to gain
significant improvements now the problem
here if you specifically do this to pre
train a classifier is the thing they
show on the right so on the left here
you have a picture of a dog right but if
you just do this self supervised you do
it without the labels so it can happen
that this image here shows up in the
negatives but it is also of a dog right
and now this image here is going to end
up maybe being this image here and you
see what happens to it it's a green one
so it's gonna get pushed apart and this
is going to make the entire task for the
later classifier much harder because if
they are pushed apart from each other
how is a linear classifier going to have
them on the same side of the decision
boundary while having everything else on
a different side right so the the task
here is implicitly making the task for
the later classifier harder by pushing
apart samples that should be of the same
class and so this is this is not
happening if you introduce a labels to
the pre training objective that's what
they do the supervised contrast
objective now you still all you want to
do is here we're going to draw the same
embedding space and we're going to draw
this original dog image and we're going
to draw the Augmented version of the
original dog image but now we also have
the following we also have these images
which are images of the same class so
we're going to put them in black here
and let's say the augmented versions
around them in smaller black thoughts
augmented versions of those right you
can augment them as well and then you
have the negative samples and the
negative samples are not just any images
but just images of different classes so
you just go over your mini batch and all
everything that's of the same class we
could becomes positives including their
augmentations and everything that is not
in the same class becomes negatives and
also you can augment them as well so now
we have a bunch of things in our
embedding space and our objective is
going simply going to be again we want
to push away all the images that
not of the same class as our original as
our red original image which is called
the anchor so all of this needs to be
pushed away but now we want to pull
together all the Augmented versions of
the original image but also we want to
pull together all of the other images of
the same class including also their
augmented version so all of this is
going to be pulled together so not only
does the let work learn about these
augmentations which again for this idea
the augmentations aren't even necessary
the network there learns a
representation space where images of the
same class are close together which
again is going to make the task of later
linear classifiers that needs to
separate this class from other classes
very very easy and again the other
images aren't just going to be pushed
away but if they're from the same class
let's say this and this image are from
the same class all of those are going to
be pushed apart from a red dot but by
themselves being pushed together to
their own cluster here of their own
class I hope this makes sense and I hope
the difference to the cross-entropy
objective is sort of clear the
cross-entropy objective simply from the
beginning just cares about which side of
the decision boundary iran while this
pre-training objective first cares to
put things close together that are in
the same class and then the decision
classifier will have a much easier time
the reason why this works better than
the because because it's not entirely
clear from the beginning that why this
should work better because it's working
with the same information it's just
because people have generally found that
these pre-training contrastive
pre-training objectives they just are
somewhat better at exploiting the
information in the data set then if you
just hammer on hammer with the
contrastive sorry
with the cross-entropy loss from the
beginning so but it is not fully
explained yet why this works better be
as it's working with the same data again
the difference here is that the previous
methods of contrastive pre-training the
self supervised ones they did not have
access to the labels and the advantage
of that is you can have a giant database
of unlabeled additional data that you do
the free training on whereas here we do
the pre training including the labels so
here the label dog is an intrinsic part
because we need to know which of these
samples we need to pull together but
that also means we cannot leverage the
may be that we have more on labelled
data and unlabeled data is pretty cheap
to obtain so that's the advantages and
disadvantages here so this new loss so
they they do compare this here and
usually in these contrastive objectives
you have somewhat like two encoders want
to encode the the anchor and want to
encode the Augmented versions and this
one is like a momentum with shared
weights and so on it all of this isn't
really important if you want to look
into that look into papers like momentum
contrast or I did one on curl for
reinforcement learning I think the the
general gist of it is clear so they
compare the formulation of their loss to
the self supervised one usually it takes
the form of things like this so the one
is the the anchor here and then the ZJ I
would be the positive example and you
see here that the inner product between
the anchor and the positive example
sorry about that
the inner product should be high because
here the loss is the negative of
whatever is here so if you minimize the
loss you say I want the inner product
between my anchor and whatever is the
positive sample to be high and all
everything else here which includes the
thing on the top but it also includes
everything else I
the inner product to be low and which is
exactly the thing where you push you
pull together the positives and you push
apart everything else the that is the
standard objective that you had before
they they extend this but looks almost
the same so compared to the unsupervised
objective now first of all they extend
this such that you can have more than
one positive sample now this is also
possible in the unsupervised way so they
just augmented by this and they also now
this is the crucial part they include
the labels into the pre turning
objective so they say everywhere where I
and J have the same label should be
maximized in the inner product so should
be pulled together while everything else
is being pushed apart yes so they say we
generalize to an arbitrary number of
positives and I also say contrastive
power increases with more negatives I
think that's just a finding that they
have that when they add more negative so
when they increase the batch size that
contrastive power increases they do
analyze their gradient which I find it's
pretty neat you can already see that if
you formulate a loss of course the
gradient is going to go in the negative
direction but they make it clear that if
you look at the gradient for the
positive cases what appears is this one
- pIJ quantity and the pIJ quantity is
exactly the inner product between I and
J normalized of course so if you minim
so the gradient is going to point into
the negative direction of that for the
positives which means you you're gonna
pull them together and it's going to
push into this direction with for the
negative classes which means you you
push them up
and they also analyze what happens a in
with relation to hardness so they say
there are two kinds of if you just look
at the positive samples there are two
kinds there are easy positives where the
network has already learned to match
them closely where the inner product is
almost one if you look at them
that means the pIJ quantity is large
right because that is basically the
inner product and you look at this term
this term is exactly what we saw in the
gradient then you see that this here
since this is one this entire thing is
zero this is all so highs this is close
to one so this entire thing is zero this
is almost zero but if you have a hard
positive where the network hasn't
learned yet to align the inner product
properly or align the representation
properly then the angle between the
things again these are normalized the
angle is they are approximately
orthogonal so the gradient magnitude is
going to be this here is going to be
approximately 0 so this is close to 1
and this here since this is also 0 is
also close to 1 so this is going to be
larger than 0 which means that their
loss focuses on the examples that are
that the network cannot yet represent
well according to their objective which
makes sense right
first of all but second of all it that
is exactly the same thing as in the
cross entropy loss if you if you look at
the cross entropy loss and you have a
situation where the network is really
good already for a given sample so it
already puts a dog into the dark class
then the the gradient will not be
pulling much for that sample it might
mainly focuses on where you're still
wrong so it is like I appreciate the
analysis but it is not a notable
difference I think what they want to
show is that their loss
if you do gradient descent really does
what it is supposed to do namely first
of all it does this polling together
pushing a part of inner products for the
positive and negative samples and it
mainly focuses on samples where you not
yet have found a good representation to
align them with others it focuses on
pairs that are not yet correctly close
or together or far apart they also
connect this to the triplet loss where
they can show after some approximation
that if their loss only has one positive
and one negative sample it is going to
be proportional to the triplet loss the
triplet loss is basically where you have
an image and you find one positive I
think there's going to be of the same
class right here and you find one
negative of a different class and you
try to push those apart while pulling
those together the problem here they say
is the problem of hard negative sampling
in order for this to make sense you need
the negative sample to be what's called
a hard negative sample so this the call
is hard negative mining because you only
have one negative sample you better make
this something where the network can
learn from right and if it's too easy
the network can't learn anything and
they're more thereby you have the
problem of hard negative mining where
you often have to filter through your
mini batch or even through your data set
to find a good negative sample to go
along with this pair of positive samples
but I don't I don't really see how their
method except that you know it has a
bunch of positives and negative samples
except for that which I guess you could
also apply to the triplet loss there's
not really a difference here again your
if your method is a contrastive method
you do have the problem that if you
simply sample at random your negative
samples are going to be become easier
and easier over the training over the
course of training and you get the
problem of at some point
you're gonna have to do actively sample
hard negatives
I think this paper just gets around it
by having huge batch sizes so yeah but
again they do get state-of-the-art on
imagenet for these types of networks and
augmentation strategies and they do look
at how their loss appears to be more
hyper parameter stable so if they change
out the augmentation if they change the
optimizer or the learning rate you can
see here that the spread in accuracy is
much smaller than for the cross entropy
loss except here but it is it is hard to
compare variances of things that don't
have the same means in terms of accuracy
so take this on the right here with a
grain of salt
they also evaluate this on corrupted
image net so there's an image net data
set where you it has several levels of
corruptness of the data set and you can
see your accuracy goes down but the
accuracy for the cross entropy loss goes
down faster than for the supervised
contrastive loss you see they start
together like this and they go further
apart now it is not clear to me whether
that's just an effect like if you just
trained a supervised contrastive loss
also to this level whether it would fall
off at the same speed or whether because
it is the supervised contrastive loss it
would kind of match that curve it's not
clear whether that's really an effect of
the difference of the losses or is just
an effect of the fact that they aren't
the same accuracy to begin with again
this kind of shifting you can't really
compare things that have different means
in the first place but that's it is an
interesting finding that their method is
more stable to these corruptions I just
want to point out at the end their
training details and just highlight they
train for up to seven hundred epochs
during the pre training stage which is I
think standard but mad
and they trained up models with batch
sizes up to 8192 so you need like a
super TPU cluster to run these kind of
things and I am never exactly trusting
of numbers like this even though it's
it's kind of a good improvement it is
still like a 1% improvement and in these
small numbers I feel I just feel the
there might be sir there might be a big
effect that things like batch sizes and
how much you put into computing how much
compute you put into it and what else
you're doing there might be so much
influence of that that I first want to
see this replicated multiple times
across the entire field before I'm going
to really trust that this is a good
thing to do alright so I hope you like
this if you're still here
thank you consider subscribing if you
have a comment please leave it I usually
read them and with that bye bye